Lo que tenemos aquí es una recta y también
tenemos un punto que no está en la recta.
Nuestro objetivo es dibujar una recta nueva que
pase por este punto y que sea perpendicular a
la recta original. ¿Cómo podemos obtenerla?
Bueno, ya sabemos que nuestro compás no será
útil ya que lo ha sido anteriormente, entonces
lo que haremos es tomar un punto arbitrario en
nuestra recta original -digamos este punto de
aquí-, después ajustaremos nuestro compás de
tal manera que la distancia entre el pivote y la
punta de mi lápiz sea la misma que la distancia
entre estos dos puntos, y ahora podemos usar
el compás para trazar un arco de ese radio,
así que allá vamos. Ahora, nuestro paso
siguiente será encontrar otro punto en
la recta original que tenga la misma distancia
a partir del punto que está fuera de la recta,
y lo encontraremos centrando el compás en
ese punto y trazando otro arco. Podemos ver
claramente que este nuevo punto también
tiene la misma distancia hasta el punto
exterior que tenemos acá arriba. Después vamos
a centrar nuestro compás en ese punto. Ojo,
observa que no hemos cambiado el radio de
nuestro compás y trazaremos otro arco como este.
Ahora, lo que haremos es conectar este
punto y este otro para crear otra recta
que parece ser perpendicular, y
vamos a demostrar que, en efecto,
sea perpendicular a nuestra recta original. Así
que déjame trazarla. Aquí la tenemos. Y ahora,
¿cómo podemos estar seguros de que esta recta
nueva que acabamos de trazar es, en efecto,
perpendicular a la recta original? Bueno,
conectemos los puntos que acabamos de hacer,
si conectamos todos los puntos dibujaremos un
rombo, porque sabemos que esta distancia es la
misma que esta distancia, que es la misma
que... que es la misma que esta. Vamos a
asegurarnos de que la trazamos derecha, que
es a su vez igual a esta otra distancia.
Entonces, este es un rombo, y sabemos que
las diagonales de un rombo se intersecan
en ángulos rectos. Así que ya lo
tenemos: hemos trazado una recta
que pasa por este punto exterior y que
es perpendicular a la recta original.